spies who have been for many years in my
hat service and did not at that time
suspect that share one day be
transferred entirely to ours was a
little inclined to desert my app during
the months that we spent in her house
there had been in my infancy before we
went to comb brain and with my aunt
layer did you still to spend the winter
in Paris with her mother a time when I'm
in front spot so little that on New
Year's Day before going into my great
aunt's house my mother put a five Frank
piece in my hand and said now be careful
don't make any mistake wait until you
hear me say good morning funds was and I
touch your arm before you give it to her
no sooner had we arrived in my haunts
dark Hall and we saw in the gloom but
needs the frills in a snowy cap is stiff
and fragile as if it had been made of
sponge shirt the concentric waves of a
smile of anticipatory baby
it was France was motionless and
directly framed in the small doorway of
the carton like the statue of a saint in
a snitch when we had grown more
accustomed to this religious darkness we
could discern it with features at this
interest in love of all humanity blended
with a tender respect for the upper
classes which raised to the most
honorable quarter for heart the hope of
receiving her New Year's gifts
mama pinched my arm sharply and said in
a loud voice good morning funds was at
this signal my fingers parted and I let
fall the coin which found a receptacle
and are confused but outstretched hand
but since we had begun to go to Cumbre
there was no one I knew better than from
sua's we were her favorites and in the
first years at least while she showed
the same consideration for us as for my
heart she enjoyed with us a keener
relish because we had in addition to our
dignity as part of the family
for she had for those invisible bonds by
which community of blood unites him
the family as much respect as any Greek
tragedy the fresh charm of not being her
customary employers and so with what joy
she would welcome us with what Sora
complained that the weather was still so
bad for us on the day of my arrival just
before Easter when there was often an
icy wind
well maman acquired after her daughter
in her nephews and if her grandson were
nice was nice and what they were going
to make of him and whether he took after
his grandmother later when no one else
was in the room mama who knew that
France woz was still mourning for her
parents we've been dead for years would
speak of them kindly asking her endless
little questions about them and their
lives
she had guessed that France was did not
like her son-in-law and that he spoiled
the pleasure she found in visiting her
daughter as a to could not talk so
freely when he was there and so one day
when France woz was going to their house
some miles from Cumbre mama said to her
with a smile tell me France was if
Julien has had to go away and you have
Marguerite to yourself all day you will
be very sorry but you will make the best
of it won't you
and Francois has answered laughing
Madame knows everything Madame is worse
than the x-rays she pronounced X with an
affectation of difficulty and with a
smile of self-deprecation her an
unlettered woman daring to employ a
scientific term the x-rays they brought
here from madame octave which see what
is in your heart and she went off
disturbed that anyone would be caring
about her perhaps anxious that she
should not see her in tears mama was the
first person who had given her the
pleasure of feeling that her present
existence with his simple joys and
sorrows might offer some interest might
be a source of grief or pleasure to
someone other than herself
Ma'at resigned herself to doing without
Francois to some extent
during our visits knowing how much my
mother appreciated the services of so
active and intelligent have made one who
looked at as a nice at five o'clock in
the morning in her kitchen under a cap
whose stiff and dazzling frills seemed
to be made of porcelain as when dress
for high mass who did everything well
who toiled like a horse whether she was
well or ill but without noise without
the appearance of doing anything the
only one of my aunts maids who when mama
asked for hot water or black coffee
would bring them actually boiling she
was one of those servants who in a
household seems least satisfactory at
first to a stranger doubtless because I
take no pains to make a conquest of him
and show him no special attention
knowing very well that they have no real
need of him that he will cease to be
invited to the house sooner than they
will be dismissed from it who on the
other hand clean with most fidelity to
those masters and mistresses who have
tested and proved their real capacity
and do not look for that superficial
responsiveness as slavish affability
which many oppress a stranger favorably
but often conceals when France was
having seen that my parents had
everything they required first went
upstairs again to give my doctor of
pepsin and to find out from her what she
would take for lunch it was very rare
for her not to be called on to give an
opinion furnish an explanation in regard
to some important event just fat see
France was Madame goopy went by more
than a quarter of an hour late to fetch
her sister if she loses any more time on
the way I would not be at all surprised
if she arise that if she arrived after
the elevation well there would be
nothing wonderful in that would be the
answer or transpose if you had come in
five minutes ago you would have seen
Madame
there go past with some asparagus twice
the size of what matter whether color
has do try and find out from her cook
where she got them you know this spring
you've been serving asparagus with
everything you might be able to get
something like these for our visitors I
wouldn't be surprised if they came from
the cure is found size would say and I'm
sure you would it my for France was my
aunt would reply shrugging her shoulders
from the Curie's indeed you know quite
well that he can never grow anything the
wretched little twigs of asparagus not
an asparagus at all I tell you that
these were stick as my arm not your arm
of course but my forearm which has gone
so much that are again this year or
France was didn't you hear that bell
just now it's split my head no poor girl
your skull must be very thick you make
thank God for that
it was my longing time to fetch doctor
people he came out with her at once I
went off along the river to a zoo there
must be some child ill oh dear dear the
poor little creature would come with a
sigh from France paws who could not hear
of any calamity but falling a person on
not to her even in some distant part of
the world without beginning to lament or
France was for whom did they sound the
death smell just now oh dear of course
it would be from enema who soon had to
think that I had forgotten that she
passed away the other night
indeed it is time the Lord called me
home too I don't know what has become of
my head since I lost my poor are tough
but I'm wasting your time my good girl
indeed no man I'm look tom my time is
not so precious whoever made our time
didn't sell it to us I am just going to
see that my fire hasn't gone out